j'ai des gens mère qui m'ont tourné le
dos et attention quand tout s'est
arrangé qui ont fait un taux complet sur
eux mêmes et qui sont revenus
donc je connaissais des gens qui
tournait le dos mais ce qu'ils font à
c'est une forme d'être humain qui est
pourri de l'intérieur quoi des
humoristes qui allait en télé me
démonter et quand j'ouvre la location de
la billetterie de mon spectacle on vend
140 mille vies en deux jours palais des
sports de cigales les mêmes mais qui
m'écrivent en dm sur instagram est ce
qu'il ya moyen de faire ta première
partie et je me dis mais où comment on
peut être comment ça existe et il vient
c'est incroyable ça est ce que vous
comprenez benjamin toi qui es qu'elle
ferait que toi tu nous tu nous a souvent
raconté ça qu'il ya des mecs non mais
sérieux c'est val d'or dans ce métier
quand vous avez un coup dur on va pas se
mentir c'est risible a vécu aussi que
vous avez un bon départ vendéen
d'hypocrites l'amérique au christ et
c'est vrai que les coups de téléphone
quand ça va mal je vais pas vous mentir
si vous en avez un ou deux c'est le
grand maximum les mêmes personnes et les
mêmes personnes qui ont rien dit ou qui
se vit dans l'ombre
on voulait envoyer que ce que ça va
mieux encore on va tu savais que c'est
insupportable
alors c'est pas que le mieux la
télévision va pas il faut pas oublier
que dès qu'on la télévision loin de là
mais c'est vrai que c'est une spécialité
n'a beaucoup mais vrai que ces
spécialités de 2,2 de gens en plus qui
ont un aplomb et celle vous savez très
bien de quoi je parle ce qu'ils vont
vous font vous défoncer alors en plus
ils le font souvent devant des gens qui
vous le répète et quand ils vouvoyaient
disent rien ça c'est la grande scène
je vous passe par derrière et après vous
ils vous font un sourire alors garde à
vue après avoir été surpris car il est
enfoncé par des gens qui paraissait
pourtant ami avec lui à tel point que
gad les avait même aidé dans le passé et
certains humoristes par exemple qui sont
connus qui sont ils ont tout eu les
respecte tu les a aidés pour des trucs
perso et tous qu'ils disent oui à malley
toute façon j'ai toujours su que tu
inventes a toujours su mais il ya un
mois on était ensemble et tu m'a demandé
de venir un ton émission puis tu m'as
demandé un service et trappes et je te
prêter de l'argent entre appelle un jour
et vous collez vous voyez à la télé à ce
moment là vous les appelez pour dernier
devant rester soir non j'attends de les
croiser eh ben la bonne surprise c'est
que je leur ai souri je leur ai dit
bonjour et je leur ai ouvert mon coeur
et mes bras et
ils se sont effondrés et la tendance en
connaît pas mais si l'idée la vérité toi
aussi tu nous la vérité est ce que tu as
eu des trucs
voilà je sais pas qui sont passés au
départ même côté moi j'ai la chance
d'être un enfant choyé de la télévision
c'est vrai
ramé oui à voir ici c'est vrai j'ai
toujours été gâté j'ai pas eu de soucis
majeurs et c'était pas des mecs qui tous
regardés de haut quand tu as rejoint
laurent par exemple ou des trucs
franchement non non non j'ai bien que
j'avais un bon avocat j'avais pierre
bénichou ah ouais c'est vrai j'avais
bien défendu donc face à lui personne ne
moufte
valérie bénaïm construit les gars de la
série chuck barris nana mais bien sûr
évidemment mais je rejoins ce que
disaient aussi aussi benjamin nous avons
traversée du désert pendant deux ans oui
et le téléphone que ce n'est plus le
téléphone ne sonne plus et à ce
moment-là ce qu'est ce qui est très très
drôle c'est que quand on a recommencé
tous les deux à travailler ensemble en
ouais tout à coup il n'y a pas fallu
attendre un mois pour que le téléphone
sonne à nouveau en disant mais comment
ça va mais tu sais que je t'aime et si
je t'avais appelé tu te souviens que
maintenant je ne me souviens pas qu'il
m'avait appelé mais s'il souviens-toi
jeu j'ai régulièrement pris des
nouvelles pas du tout sans aller très
loin
laon ce moment à des pmp on a ou on a
collé raid et des sources de ouf et je
sens bien avant les niveaux je suis pas
l'animateur mais bon travail ensemble
je vois bien que ça change le téléphone
rouge sonne et on reçoit des messages y
avait pas ça il ya six mois oui moi
quand c'était un peu plus compliqué
personnes nous appeler c'est un peu le
propre de ce métier on fait le tri